mein name ist mit der liebe freunde
herzlich willkommen heute endlich mal
wieder seine neuen episoden luca teams
ich habe mal wieder absolut gar keinen
bock
denn jetzt werde ich quasi acht minuten
lang durch gemobbt luca heute kommt ein
neues video auch luca video kommt morgen
ja das video hier sollte eigentlich auch
schon gestern kommen doch dann kam was
seit bestehen dieser moment wenn dein
gesicht einfach schon genug ist
ja dieses sein
aber mobbing jetzt wenn mich einer fragt
wie ich lukas kanal bis das traurige ist
halt
das ist einfach wahr sich nach einem
luca wie die video ganz so schlimm ist
sehr gut luca sieht einen mini klatschen
durchs zimmer laufen ja ich kann wieder
klatschen noch kann ich hier gerade
rumlaufen
also ich kann schon rumlaufen problem
ist nur dass ich dann ich versuche auch
ein cooles spiel selbst zu machen auch
ich
wo ist das bitte nicht gültig es gibt
sie noch
das geht tief in mein herze kriegt eine
anzeige
meine beste freundin und ich wenn der
lehrer sagt die sollen ruhig sein dass
wann schönes foto aus dem pool im urlaub
habe heute ein buch so löst du 50 seiner
probleme gesehen luca 24 fuchs hat sich
gleich zwei jäger
ich will das nicht mehr es kommt ich
weiß das
richtig gut bei euch ankommt aber bei
mir halt daneben auch mein herz ist so
wie man lieber den daumen das wetter
zurzeit ist wie ich in mathe hat keine
ahnung was ich war nicht so scheiße in
mathe liga die die ganze zeit durch
durch sprachen lernen
wenn ich später mal detektiv bin nenne
ich mich mysteriös das ist nicht wahr
das ist nicht wahr
das sind einfach neue tiefpunkte die
hier erreicht werden ein kleiner witz am
rande man ey com
ich will nicht mehr was luca sehen würde
wenn ich vor ihm steht
das war erkennt dass er mich also
vielleicht das weil ich bin so groß und
so ein lappen und aber das war gar nicht
so schlimm ist nur von guten weg pro
anti mobbing und dieser moment wenn
deine mutter sagt du sollst aufstehen du
hast dann aber in letzter sekunde tu's
wenn sie in dein zimmer kommt immer so
gewesen immer so gewesen jedoch immer so
bleiben und es wird auch immer so
bleiben dass wir in einem rein kommt
oder dein dad und wenn sie wieder
rausgehen dass sie dann einfach nicht
die tür zumachen
die gehen raus schreit so weiter auf die
das gehört ja da draußen irgendwas zu
gemacht wie nennt man höfliche
autofahrer geisterfahrer sie sind immer
so entgegenkommend
das ist irgendwann dann auch wirklich
einfach nicht mehr lustig wo wohnt ein
armer franzose im baguette sodass
[Musik]
ich frage mich was in euren köpfen
vorgeht dieser moment wenn deine mutter
setzte er findet die du nie gesagt hast
immer so immer so
damit fällt jetzt kein beispiel ein
aberwitz was ich mal ein medikament
bitte lagere mich bei 25 grad in
dachgeschosswohnungen hold my beer ja
das stimmt
ich sage nicht die ganze zeit nur das
stimmt das hat die wahrheit wie lange
kann man ohne gehirn leben keine ahnung
wie alt bist du
daumen tut wm man das näher mein opa kam
mit einem bein aus dem krieg zurück wir
wissen immer noch nicht wie es geht
ist doch ich will kommt oft sonnenschein
wie hieß der erste chinese der korona
hatte hat irgendwer hat euch doch
irgendwann mal ins hirn geschissen oder
auf der arbeit nennen mich alle 007 null
ahnung null bock 7000 so viel also ich
hab echt jetzt also der daten wenn deine
mutter nach die ruf du fragst was ist
und sie einfach nicht mehr antwortet
immer so immer so reiht sich direkt ein
mit dem tür nicht zu machen und
letzte ausdenken damals alzheimer kickt
schon rein bei mir ich hab so angst herr
doktor das ist meine erste operation
keine sorge meine auch hoch wer hat als
kind auch immer wettrennen mit
regentropfen gespielt was wettrennen mit
regentropfen regentropfen
von oben wenn man läuft läuft man
horizontal und nicht fertig ich habe
euch in vielen erbärmlichen zuständen
gesehen luca 24 de helmut o mein gott
das ist so wahr wenn ich mir überlege
wie oft ich dem dhl boten schon
irgendwie halten die tür aufgemacht habe
völlig verkatert noch mit irgendwie
zahnpasta und zahnbürste im mund also
der muss ich wirklich denken ja da kommt
in letzter zeit gar nicht mehr stellt
die pakete immer nur unten ab vielleicht
kommt er deswegen nicht mehr zu mir der
moment wenn der aufhält das harry potter
auf deutsch harald töpfer heißen würde
das ist einfach genau so unlustig wie
dieses harald peter kurth kindergrab
witt gerieten
dieser moment wenn dich jemand winkt du
zurück bist sondern merkst dass du gar
nicht gemeint war ist immer so ich
glaube mir hat noch nie jemand selbst
gefunden so ich jetzt ja selber durch
ähnlichen kamera bildschirm ich bin echt
ein opfer dieser moment wenn du dein
handy aus der tasche holt um zu sehen
wie viel uhr es ist es dann zurück
steckt und dann keine ahnung hast wie
spät es ist ja das kenne ich das ist
genauso wie wenn man im haus irgendwie
was sucht bzw sich irgendwie was holen
wir beispielsweise aus der küche dann
geht man in die küche dort ist man in
der küche und warum war ich jetzt hier
dann geht man zurück und dann steckt man
a
stimmt ich wollte den kühlschrank aus
dem fenster schmeißen neun jahre altes
ich wie ich auf dem rückweg im auto
meiner augen zu habe und versuche zu
raten wo wir gerade sind das mache ich
immer noch das mache ich immer wenn ich
im taxi sitze abend sie mache dann
irgendwie die augen zu und überlegen
sócrates haben wir links das heißt wir
müssen jetzt an dem feld seien jetzt
fahren wir rechts und das heißt jetzt
sind wir dann dem fluss gelandet
können sie mich dann rauslassen ich
schwimme dann den rest auf der dose
steht spülmaschinenfest würde gerne
hingehen steht aber nicht darauf wann
und wo das stattfinden wird dass das
spülmaschinenfest
foto bak heute das wirst du verstehen
wenn du älter bist ich älter verstehe es
immer noch nicht richtig es genauso wie
das mit dem weihnachtsmann sophie
findest du dass ich ein guter vater bin
ich heiße sandra mehr und dollar kann
ich nicht klatschen
mein daumen tut noch ein bisschen weh
allerdings war das dass der zudem für
die heutige episode luca mit euch
gefallen hatte lasten glauben da muss
nichts kaputt und werde noch kein
abonnent von meinem kanal seit meine
lieben freunde würde ich euch ganz doll
raten unter dem video einfach mal